welcome back to grammar unfiltered
hosted by me josh smith and today we're
joined by the star of necklace's fate
the wink saga is abigail cohen
[Music]
hey how are we doing
we are doing great side scared
the winning emotions over the emotions
because this is like it's such an
intense
role your role in this show
how on earth when you're taking on this
leading lady role
you're stepping into that zone how do
you mentally prepare yourself for that
level of pressure
geez um i mean you kind of don't
i mean it's like i found out
the i think like a week or two before i
had to fly out
so i definitely it it was a huge
shock and i had never had a role
this i mean big before where i was
working day in day out with a bunch of
lines to know and
yeah just kind of in the center of a
show which is really terrifying so
how do you prepare i mean i think you
just kind of have to roll with the
punches once you get there and then
just hope for the best kind of fake it
till you make it i guess
the wink saga is all about they're all
coming of age in different ways and
they're all realizing different things
about themselves their power
and their power like in a physical sense
but also
um in a mental sense as well for you
what's been some sort of turning points
in your sort of like coming of age story
would you say
i would definitely say
when i was around that age like the
i'd say actually more like middle school
to high school
time i was very bullied in
middle school for actually having red
hair
um and just like brutal
stuff you know written on the internet
written like it was just when stuff
was like um or like group chats were
starting to become a thing on the
internet i think it was like through
gmail
it was like all of these kids at my
school like joined in we're just talking
about
um just something that you know
my hair that made me different i was
probably like the only
ginger in the in the
in my class or whatever but um
in that time you know you don't want to
feel different you want to fit in
you want to be just like everyone else
and that
for me was a very traumatic experience
it really grew me
like it made me have to learn to
love what makes me different and i think
that's also
what this show is really
you know talking about and really
represents is that like
you know all these girls have actual
superpowers but
if you want to talk about it in a real
life sense
everyone has a superpower it's just
your superpower is what makes you
different you know
and then once you embrace it that's when
it becomes powerful and that's when you
are powerful
and i just think there's so much truth
in that and
i think that it's such a beautiful
message for so many
young men and women going through
whatever they're going through because
those years are horrible
and hard and messy and confusing
you use it kind of to fuel you forward
in some ways
yes and no i
the last thing i want i think maybe
that's kind of a
i mean that might just be human nature
kind of be like
wanting to prove people wrong um
i don't know if i want to
live in my career
and in my life like that because also i
feel like if i were to
it could also be kind of a recipe for
disaster because
you know so many people once they get to
the level that they've been
hoping to get to and it's to like prove
everyone wrong they get there and
they're kind of like
okay what now you know because they're
not doing it out of like
the goodness of their own heart and out
of like the love for the craft they're
doing it out of like a
fu type of situation so i definitely i
mean
i would be lying if i haven't felt that
feeling of like
anger and like i want to go get there
but i also
i want to check in with myself a lot and
i want to like hold myself accountable
and be like whoa whoa whoa whoa that's
not
a good way to live we need to forgive we
need to love we need to understand and
give grace
and recognize that you know
also hurt people hurt people you know
so it's like those kids that probably
were bullies at that time
were probably going through their own
like
hard hard stuff like you never know you
know
so i also want to remind myself of that
as well but
to answer your question yes and no
but i think as well like success that
comes back to what success means doesn't
it because
you have to dictate success by your own
standards and not by everything external
all the time because if you're always
doing it to be like
i need to get this show or i need to get
to a certain number of instagram
followers to feel
validated then you're never going to
feel fully validated within
no it's so true it's so true i mean
that's why it's an age-old story of like
the most you know successful people are
usually the loneliest and it's because
i think it's all about intention like if
you're if you're doing it
for exactly like the reason of
a validation or to fill a void like
you're never gonna
that's the kind of funny part of it is
that you're never gonna fill it because
you're never gonna get enough validation
because all you're doing is focusing on
it and there's so many people in the
world
you're gonna have to go get it from that
person and that person and that person
but if you just like
focus on you and what your heart wants
and how
you can also then impact other people's
lives and love on other people
and have community and loved ones around
you
i think that is the ultimate form of
success while also doing what you love
and creating what you love you know
away from the screen and also working
how do you look after
your mental health would you say how do
you how do you manage it
definitely i've learned i'm an introvert
so but i can get carried away with kind
of
um i guess
people pleasing in a sense of like
forgetting that i'm an introvert and
really overextending myself so
making sure that i do listen and check
in with myself a lot
and see if i'm getting kind of
overstimulated or see if i'm feeling
really heavy
or just exhausted and listening to that
and honoring that
um that's been a really
big thing in my life that i've had to
learn to kind of um
manage because i'm pretty bad at that
but that really helps with me
um therapy as well it's really wonderful
i'm all about therapy i think we need to
normalize it more
and just get people talking and get
people
um kind of just in touch with their
emotions and their
their past and realizing why certain
people do things and why you feel
a certain way it's i mean that's been
life-changing for me as well
what do you think you've learned about
yourself and what maybe the lessons
you've taken away about yourself healing
isn't linear like you're gonna
there will be times where you don't feel
your best self and that's okay and to be
patient with yourself and to continue on
this whole concept of beauty is such a
charged
concept in itself anyway how's your
relationship with
the concept and idea of beauty changed
throughout your life and how have you
become at one with your own
beauty and your own self from what i was
saying before i mean
i think of course when you know when
you're young
you especially as
a young woman you you know all you see
are
the you see media and you see you know
people's
idea image of beauty or
or even like where you grow up you know
i grew up in in florida
and you know i'm a pale redhead and i
was surrounded by
tan blondes and i was like and they're
beautiful to me and i was like
if only i could be that my entire life
and
um that definitely fed into a lot of you
know and i think but i think everyone
has that
like they want what they don't have and
i think it all go like boils down to
embracing what makes you different is
what also makes you beautiful like i
really do believe that and i think that
it's not you know this
you know the perfect facial features or
the perfect you know the perf whatever
the perfect body is because that changes
all the time
i think i really do think that if
men and women just embraced what in
personality wise you know
outward appearance whatever just
embraced what
that little thing was that also is a
little bit of their insecurity
embraced it fully and then kept
reminding themselves that it is
beautiful
and other people can remind them that
it's beautiful because it also does
unfortunately
there are so many insecurities in
society and within
you know people because other people
also then
will call them unattractive or call them
ugly and it's not always them hating
themselves it also does come from other
people because comparison is just the
robber of joy right
that is so true because you can sit
there and wonder
especially in this culture that we're
now in where we're literally looking at
ourselves
day in and day out like i'm looking at
myself now like
obviously intently listening to you but
before i came i was like oh my god i
look so
red i look blotchy what's going on and
you spend so much time that she
looking at yourself now in ways we never
did before so you can't see going like
wow like do i need a little something
here do i need this do i need that like
that's what's so bad as well isn't it
we're comparing ourselves how we looked
on zoom
a day ago i'm telling you yes and on top
of it oh yeah the zoom stuff is yeah
exactly you're having a conversation
with someone you're just like talking
directly to them
yeah yeah but how you have the ability
to be like
you're like oh god oh no i'm listening
i'm listening yes
it's great no i mean i also think too
it's like
instagram is wonderful in its own way i
think it's great that it connects
people and you know has you know
gives room for new types of conversation
and
and ideas but on the other hand it is
i think to a
fault so
about perfectionism that
it is kind of right now like it's
worrying me
with our i think it's getting better i
hope
but and i think people are catching on
but i think for a bit it's been
i mean i've been i've
experienced it i i i scroll through and
i i compare myself all the time and it's
and then i have to you know i feel like
i have to remind myself and be like whoa
whoa again like this isn't everyone is
everyone is a lot of people i'm not
going to say everyone are putting on a
show they don't want to show the true
like what's going on right now actually
i didn't feel like getting out of bed
today because i'm
kind of feeling gross or i'm feeling
like today or
what or i just cried 30 minutes ago but
now i'm fine here's a picture of me
on the beach and turks and caicos but
like i think you know i think
authenticity is also so important in
this day and age
on on our social media platforms because
we also have
my concern is for the young people
going on and you know it's their really
like their brains are still developing
this is what's going to be kind of
ingrained into their minds of like
i have to look like this one day i hope
i look like that one day or i hope i'm
there one day and it's like
baby that's not real like that's that's
like
that's not real so like don't try to be
like go try to
love you and be you but it's so hard
when it's just in front of our faces all
the time
it's it's concerning you know
sit the you down who was like the same
age as your character so you're a high
schooler
minus those magical powers we've been
talking about
and you could sit her on here and you
could give her a piece of advice
what would you want to say to her
i would say keep going because
everything's going to be okay
i know that sounds so like cliche but
you know there are so many times where i
just felt
kind of hopeless at times
just in that in that during that age i
if i'm being completely honest
and if i were to sit myself down i would
definitely be like
get up keep going
and set that world on fire and go set
that world on fire
flames but don't actually
you